Pixar is 2008 animated film.
Wally is a critically
acclaimed masterpiece,
about two adorable robots
falling in love. The, I'd argue,
it also serves as an excellent
example of sociological storytelling
like most of the best science fiction.
This movie uses imaginative visions of
the future as a lens through which to
interrogate the social systems of today.
Now,
in order to explore how
well he accomplishes this,
we need to start with something that
makes this movie relatively unique and
that's the fact that it
doesn't have a villain,
at least not the kind we've come to
expect from a Disney owned a studio.
This is how he handled things down.
Hollywood loves its larger
than life cartoonish billings.
The villainous characters that appear on
the big screen are typically framed as
bad apples.
They do bad things because of their
personal deficiencies and nefarious
intention by
this formula makes for a simple
easy to understand plotlines,
but it also tends to reinforce
an individualistic worldview.
The individualistic worldview is a false
but widespread way of thinking in which
society is reduced to a
bunch of individuals home
making their own independent
choices.
The central idea.
Underpinning the individualistic model
of the world is that people do what they
are.
People do bad things
because they are bad people.
According to this reductive framework,
injustice is a result of the
isolated actions of a few bad apples,
how day,
but that worldview,
like the Hollywood narratives that
are constructed around it minimizes or
completely ignores the important role
that social systems and institutions play
in our world
world.
Just build an economy.
Since Wally's narrative isn't built
around that traditional villain formula,
the movie presents us with a very
different worldview, a sociological one.
It's not that this story doesn't have
antagonists or central conflicts.
It has both.
They just don't take the forms were
used to seeing in popular entertainment,
kosher ro robots.
The antagonist of Wally is the
film setting itself, the axiom,
starlight,
or more specifically the automated
systems that run the ship in words.
The villain of this movie is not a person.
It's an institution.
I should briefly mentioned that
the axioms, AI is named audit,
but unlike how 9,000 or other AI
villains auto is not sentient,
nor are his actions the result of a
malfunction auto can't make independent
choices.
All he can do is follow his preprogrammed
directives and in that sense,
auto isn't a traditional Disney villain.
Instead,
he functions as the voice of
the ship as an institution.
Okay. Let's quickly recap the plot
for those who haven't seen this movie.
Recently,
humans have abandoned earth
after polluting the planet
to the point where it's
no longer inhabitable.
The surviving population lives aboard
massive luxury star liners that are
drifting through space.
These automated galaxy cruisers are run
entirely by robots on behalf of the buy
in large corporation.
By and large,
by in large is essentially a
combination of Walmart, Mcdonald's,
Disney,
Ge,
and Starbucks all rolled into one time.
The company promised the
original passengers that
they would all be returned to
Earth once the planet
made little girl again.
There's plenty of space.
We'll clean up the mess while you're away.
That was over 700 years ago.
The jewel of the VNL fleet.
Over several generations.
The human passengers have
become so complacent in their
over indulgent lifestyle
that they've even forgotten how to walk
under their own power remains stationary.
The film's core conflict revolves
around individuals of both the human and
robotic variety,
realizing they're all participating in
a system larger than themselves and then
working together to break
free from that system.
And that premise that we as individuals
are always participating in something
larger than ourselves is the core concept
underpinning the field of sociology.
Those larger things that we're all
participating in are referred to as social
systems. Social systems are
interconnected arrangements,
structures and relationships that combine
to form a coherent hole as individual
members of society.
We are all always participating in
a range of different social systems.
So for example,
the family unit is a social system as
our schools and police departments and
corporations and whole
patriarchy and white supremacy are also
examples of complex interlocking social
systems. To paraphrase
sociologists, Alan G. Johnson,
it's the dynamic relationship between us
as individuals and these larger social
systems that makes social life happen
because the axiom Starliner functions
as a self contained social system.
Let's use it to help illustrate
how all of this works.
Like all social systems.
The axiom includes sets of rules or social
norms which participants are expected
to adhere to in order to ensure
that the system functions smoothly.
In sociological terms,
these socially enforced expectations
are referred to as paths of least
resistance
in the movie.
We can see this process play out in the
directives that each of the robots must
follow and it's represented by literal
lines along which both the passengers and
the crew travel around the ship.
It's important to note that paths of
least resistance do not determine the
behavior of all individual human beings.
We are not robots after all,
and that means that we all have a choice
in how we participate in these social
systems. We can, if we choose,
step off the path of least resistance,
but doing so will likely lead to pressure
from others to get us back in line.
Let your timeline with
an important message.
The most succinct description of how paths
of least resistance operate that I've
ever seen uses the board game monopoly.
The monopoly example along with many of
the other concepts we've been discussing
can be found in the excellent book,
the forest and the trees by a sociologist,
Allen g Johnson.
He points out that monopoly functions
as a mini social system like all social
systems.
The game includes paths of least
resistance which can be found in the rules
inside the box.
All we really have to do is glance at
those rules and we can predict exactly how
people's behavior will be impacted.
Why don't we play me the path of least
resistance for players is to simply
follow the rules.
Refusing to adhere to the rules will
lead to push back from other players and
likely get you kicked out of the game
whenever the rules of the game are
followed and antagonistic.
Pattern of behavior will always emerge.
Guidance and that pattern
is one of a ruthless greed.
You're a little light here, dad. I'm
good for the rest. You know, I am.
Remember the game of monopoly is over
when one player has taken everything of
value from everyone else
to three way you little
laughter
as Johnson reminds us,
if we use an individualistic lens
to explain this pattern of behavior,
it leads to one explanation.
People are greedy.
Remember that the core idea underpinning
the individualistic worldview is that
people do what they are.
So according to that,
people playing monopoly behave ingredient
ways because people are greedy.
Now the problem with that as
Johnson points out is that
most people don't behave
in ruthlessly greedy ways when
they're not playing monopoly. Sure,
all people have the capacity
for selfishness to some degree,
but the rules of monopoly not
only encouraged Gri behavior,
the rules actually make greedy behavior,
a necessary condition of participation.
The personal values of the players are
irrelevant to describing the game and its
rules. It doesn't matter if you're a
Buddhist monk or a Wall Street banker.
If you play monopoly as
it's meant to be played,
you'll end up acting
like an absolute monster.
Yeah.
Paths of least resistance and their
outcomes vary greatly depending on which
social system we're talking about.
So in monopoly,
the outcome is greed on the axiom.
However,
the path of least resistance
for the passengers is to
be passive super consumers.
Many film reviewers noted that Wally
functions as a critique of consumer
capitalism, which it
undoubtedly does. However,
the film doesn't take the easy
route by vilifying individual,
by and large consumers.
In that way,
it's the opposite of
a film like idiocracy,
which is a movie I absolutely despise.
Idiocracy is also meant as
a critique of consumerism,
but it traffics in a brand of cynical,
elitist humor that ends
up blaming individuals,
often the most powerless and poorest of
people for the destructive actions of
corporations and governments.
To its credit,
that's not how Wally frames the
humans living aboard the axiom.
Starliner yes, they're complicit
in their situation and yes,
they enjoy the privileges
the system affords them.
If we were to use an individualistic
lens to explain their behavior,
we would be forced to conclude that the
captain and all the passengers acting
lazy, stupid, and apathetic ways
because they are naturally lazy,
stupid,
and apathetic people.
But since Wally is an example
of sociological storytelling,
it frames the passengers and the captain
as initially acting in the ways they do
because that's what the axioms
social systems expect from them.
Even the passengers,
physical appearance is a direct result
of the ship's systems and not a result of
their personal failings.
They are simply following the paths of
least resistance that are laid out for
them,
and that means the passengers are not
defined by their complicit role in that
system. They have the capacity
to grow and break free,
and I'd argue that that idea that people
can change how we engage with social
systems and in so doing transform or even
abolish those systems isn't incredibly
hopeful.
Message
paths of least resistance in the real
world are rarely as well defined as the
directives aboard the axiom
or the rules of a board game.
The social expectations in our daily
lives are often unwritten and we can form
to their norms unconsciously.
For example,
imagine you hear someone tell a
sexist joke, we saw your boobs,
we saw your boots. The Path least
resistance is typically to laugh.
Imagine shouldn't being confronted with
sexual harassment in the workplace.
The path of least resistance
there might be to stay silent.
The issue of men speaking out has been
a big talking point with this scandal
with many who have worked with Weinstein.
Remaining quiet,
predatory sexual behavior is not just
the result of a few very rotten apples.
It's part of a much
larger systemic problem.
Social Systems of male entitlement work
to reinforce excuse and enable that type
of behavior.
Social Systems are one of
the most important and one
of the most misunderstood
concepts in my work around
media and masculinity.
From time to time I'll
use terms like misogyny,
patriarchy and male privilege or male
entitlement and that tends to elicit a
very defensive reaction,
especially from guys who feel they're
being personally condemned as villains.
However, these terms are not meant as
an indictment of every individual man.
They're simply ways of
describing the larger social
systems that were all part of
one of LNG Johnson's key insights from
the monopoly example is that we can
describe the game of monopoly and
its outcome without describing the
personalities of each individual player.
This also means that we can describe the
framework of real world social systems
without necessarily saying anything
about the personalities of the people
participating in those systems.
The passengers and rebellious robots
aboard the axiom all eventually step off
the path of least resistance,
and as a result,
change the fate of humanity and we as
people in the real world can collectively
step off our own paths of least
resistance and refuse to be complicit in
oppressive social systems.
Thanks for watching.
If you like these long form video essays,
please consider going over to Patrion
and helping to fund the project there.
There's also a link to paypal
in the description below.
Everything I make is entirely
funded by viewers like you.
Next month we'll be
talking about George Lucas,
manhood and the star wars prequels,
so that should be fun.